Bảo số mì một tên Quốc tế Mát Mô đang tiến phở đất liền,
chực tiếp ảnh hưởng đứng bà sinh bay bên đồn các bi và đội bài.
Cô hàng không Việt Nam yêu cầu cơ sân bay này, chực sến hai thư trên hai thư,
ra sốt hạ tần và trên phai phương án phòng chủ báo để đảm bảo ăn tòn bay.
Tung công ty cảnh hàng không Việt Nam, phủ hộ các đơn vị kiểm tra kết cấu,
hệ thống thung tiên nhằm phát hiện và sử lý sự có kip thời.
Các sân bay thọt sôn vinh và định biên cũng được càng báo chủ đồng uống pháo trong trường hợp báo trên hướng.
Các công chình đáng thí công tại sân bay phải trên bị dừng kỹ thuật khi thời tí sấu,
chúng ta mửa tử tiếp hàng không sẽ liên tục cập dịch diễn báo,
khổ chợi điều hình bay, các hạn hàng không được yêu cầu điều trình linh bay phủ hộ báo đảm ăn phản phẩm tự đối.